from the point of view of the historical prospects and
strategic interests of the Russian
state, even in 10 to 15 years
this is unacceptable. We understand that
Russia is not going to fight with Europe. Yes,
we are not going to now, but the
leadership of the United States is saying that
if NATO does, that is, if Russia wins in Ukraine now  they are
not needed now and will not be needed in the future,
they deliberately dragged us and
Europe into this conflict, they achieved
their goal in this sense,
they pulled Russia and Europe apart, and now they are
also shifting the burden of
financial responsibility and
payments onto Europe,
leading
industries saving the euro,
but also in the political
changes are taking place in the consciousness of many peoples of Europe, but
they see that the United States is brazenly
mercilessly exploiting Europe in its own
interests. And those countries that have lost
these territories and, above all, Poland and the
fifth see
returning in this sense only Russia
could be the guarantor of the territorial
integrity of
Ukraine do not want do not
need History  everything will be put in its place,
we won’t interfere, but we won’t
give up ours, that’s what everyone should understand, and in
Ukraine, those who are aggressive
towards Russia, we will always be faithful to the
cause for which our comrades in arms gave their lives, I
ask you to honor their memory with a moment of
silence for the
events of this year  we have confirmed all
this, we see the West continues to wage a
hybrid war against Russia, actively supplies the
Kiev regime with intelligence information in
real time, sends
military advisers, transfers modern
weapons systems,
and the activity of the NATO military bloc has increased sharply recently,
aircraft, and the number of
Alliance troops in Eastern and Central
Europe has increased.  he is not giving up his strategy of
containing Russia and his
aggressive goals in Ukraine
Well, we are not going to give up our
goals of a special military operation
on the line of
combat contact, we can
say with confidence howl have the
initiative, we need what we want where we
need it where you are commanders  in general, they
consider it advisable to adhere to the
tactics of active defense, and this is what is
happening. And where necessary, we are improving our
positions; all attempts, as they said in the
West, to inflict a military defeat on us; a
strategic defeat; the
courage and fortitude of our soldiers in
the conditions of the changing nature of military
threats and
political risks has significantly increased the
role  nuclear Triad which provides a
balance of power, a strategic balance of power in the
world